Matt Welch here with my co-author Nick
Gillespie of the Declaration of
Independence how libertarian politics
can fix what's wrong with America we're
having asked a libertarian day to here
here in Reason HQ and the latest
question comes from Eric Schmidt via
Facebook
what is the libertarian view of health
care and what can be done to fight it
Nick yeah well I'd I guess it's a fight
the Obama health care reform there's no
question that Obama care gets virtually
a hundred percent thumbs down from
libertarians primarily for a cut you
know for two basic reasons one is that
it includes a mandate which is troubling
from all sorts of perspectives and is
gonna be fought out in the Supreme Court
that clearly is gonna be the problem but
then there's a much larger question
because even if you could get everybody
to opt into the system the way that it's
been told there is no pricing mechanism
really in that system and this is the
problem again and again with the health
care system both in the so-called
private sector as well as in the public
sector whether it's Medicare or Medicaid
our health care system is believed to
somehow organize itself in ways that are
not at all like every other sector of
the economy which is that people buy and
sell stuff based on their perceptions of
what they want and the value worth it
price signals are completely absent from
the health care system are virtually
completely absent always and only
because of government regulations and
that is the problem so the problem with
the health care reform is that there are
no market signals in it and that means
it's never going to work very well what
can be done to fight it is to publicize
that and put out alternatives recentiy V
Reason magazine other free-market think
tanks have put out volume voluminous
material that shows how you can take the
same things that work in food delivery
or in selling widgets will work wonders
in health care to get more better health
care to more and more people